Stars showing their support on the
picket lines as the rider strike enters
day two and is already having a Rippling
effect through Hollywood
our solidarity of so many people you
know we're only as good as the writing
we get
standing here for older writers because
they're not currently
paid fairly for it sort of as simple as
that I think this is one of the most
consequential hot girl Summers of our
times it's time to get real
we are nothing without their words
John Cryer Justine Bateman Natasha Leone
SNL Alum 80 Bryant and Jay Leno who
handed out Donuts all joined the wga
strikers as they seek better
compensation from Studios and streamers
last night all late night shows were
forced to air reruns I'll do whatever I
can to support them I need my writers
for Jimmy Fallon that means financial
support one of his staffers took to
Twitter revealing quote Jimmy Fallon got
NBC to give us a second week of pay and
he will be paying us himself for a third
week solidarity hey Pete are you getting
some material for SNL tonight I figured
you are
Pete Davidson's SNL return as host has
been canceled daytime soap operas could
also soon pause production as for why
the writers are on strike the Riders are
on strike because they are not being
compensated for their streaming work
like they were being compensated in the
past there's no doubt that a lot of
shows are going to be affected by this
Rider strike right now HBO's House of
the Dragon is continuing to shoot they
say that the scripts are done the
scripts are also done for this weekend's
MTV movie and TV Awards so it will Air
as planned I'm member of w and I hope
that we're able to
rectify this
depending on how long the strike goes on
return dates for shows like Abbott
Elementary are up in the air whatever
this is It's Over
the yellowjacket showrunner revealed
their season three writer's room shut
down after just one day Jane Fonda who's
out promoting her new film book club the
next chapter showed her support I think
we all do understand why they strike the
trouble is that the crews the the below
the line people are going to suffer a
lot
[Music]